welcome back to las vegas now bumble
breeze the sponsors of this next segment
is giving us the buzz on tankless water
heaters and indoor air quality check it
out
hi my name is scott sales manager with
bumble breeze plumbing heating and air
we are a service provider here in las
vegas valley that specialize in customer
service customer experience and
installation of high efficiency air
conditioning systems along with high
efficiency plumbing products as you can
see here this is one of our tankless
water heaters the biggest benefit is
we're not storing a large amount of
water in our garage that's susceptible
to leaking another benefit is families
will not run out of hot water these
systems will produce up to 12 gallons of
hot water endlessly also we're not
heating water when we're not using it so
they're extremely energy efficient here
at bumble breeze we offer upgraded
filtration systems with filters that
last up to a year we also offer indoor
humidification which is great for
customers moving in from out of town
that are not used to our dry climate
here and then uv lights benefits of uv
lights are
germs
most of the uv lights will kill common
flu viruses also will help with odors
and keeping dust down in the home
importance of yearly maintenance is huge
a lot of the stuff in the air
conditioning and your heating system is
kind of a domino effect so fixing a
small issue now can prevent to larger
issues in the future you can always
expect a friendly on-time technician
and exceptional customer service and
satisfaction we encourage customers to
give us a buzz take advantage of our
yearly maintenance and also nv energy
powershift rebate program is going on
right now which we are matching and you
can receive up to 2400
on upgrading your system to a more
energy efficient
thank you bumble breeze for sponsoring
this segment for more information call
702-563-9309
or visit bumblebreez.com and they're
matching nevada energy rebates up to
2400
when upgrading your hvac system alright
we'll be right back right here on las
vegas now